There is a misconception about chameleons
that they change their color in order to blend
in with their environment.
That is actually not the case.
When a chameleon is calm it is green and so
it naturally blends in with its leafy surroundings.
But male chameleons change color when they
become excited in the presence of a female
or a rival male, as shown here.
I will put the first frame in the bottom right
for comparison.
As you can see, as he becomes more excited,
his color changes to be more yellow orange
and red.
So instead of blending in this chameleon will
now stand out.
But how do chameleons actually change their
color?
For years we thought that there was a simple
well-established mechanism for this color
change.
In their skin, chameleons have different cells
containing colored pigments.
Some are yellow others are red and some contain
the dark melanin pigment.
Many animals including chameleons are known
to turn a darker shade by causing the melanin
to spread out along the fingery extensions
of the cell.
They turn lighter again by condensing the
pigment back into one spot.
It was assumed that chameleons must turn yellow,
orange and red in the same way, by causing
those pigments to spread out in those cells.
But new research from collaborating groups
of physicist and biologists at the University
of Geneva shows that this is incorrect.
Now the first clue should come from the fact
that there is actually no green pigment in
the a chameleon.
The green color actually created by two distinct
mechanisms, pigment color and structural color.
Beneath the yellow pigment cells, there are
cells containing tiny 130 nm crystals regularly
arranged in a lattice.
Now light diffracts off these crystals and
due to the spacing between them, blue light
constructively interferes and is therefore
strongly reflected.
Whereas the other colors are not reflected.
This is very similar to how a morpho butterfly
wing creates an iridescent blue.
There is no blue pigment just the periodic
nanoscale structure that acts as a strong
reflector for only one color.
So a chameleon looks green due to the combination
of the yellow light from the pigment plus
the blue light reflected off the crystal structure
beneath it.
So how do chameleons change this green into
yellow orange and red?
Well previously it was assumed that the color
change was achieved by dispersing pigments
in the colored cells.
But now scientists have found it's actually
the crystals underneath which are changing.
By increasing the spacing between the crystals
the chameleons can change which color is selectively
reflected.
Bigger gaps between the crystals are better
at reflecting longer wavelengths.
So as the spacing increases, the color changes
from blue to green to yellow, and then orange
and red.
Scientists compared skin samples from calm
green chameleons and excited yellow chameleons
and found that indeed, in the excited chameleon
the crystal spacing was much further apart.
Here you can see a single cell enlarged and
the color it reflects changing from blue to
green to yellow, orange and red.
Plus, a computer simulation of the light reflected
off crystals while their spacing is decreasing
also provides excellent agreement with these
observations.
Furthermore, applying physical pressure to
the skin causes the crystals to compress and
so they reflect more blue.
When that pressure is removed, the crystals
expand again reflecting more green light.
The structure of a chameleon’s skin gets
even more fascinating, as there is another
layer of cells underneath which also contain
crystals.
But these crystals are larger more spaced
out and more disorganized.
This means they reflect longer wavelengths
in the infrared part of the spectrum and they
reflect a broader range of these wavelengths.
It’s thought that the function of this layer
could be to reflect light from the sun since
these chameleons live in bright full-sun habitats.
So male chameleons don't change their color
by spreading out red and yellow pigments.
Instead they do something much more remarkable.
They actively tune the spacing between nanoscale
crystals in order to create structural colors
that span the whole length of the visible
spectrum.
Now what I find amazing is that in this day
and age we thought we had the answer to how
chameleons change color, but it actually took
the combined expertise of physicists and biologists
working together to figure out what's really
going on.
This episode of Veritasium was supported by
Linda.com a leading online learning platform
with over 3000 video courses taught by experts
in areas ranging from video production to
web development and computer programming.
Chances are if you can think of a topic, they
have a course that teaches it.
Now as part of this sponsorship they are offering
Veritasium viewers a 10 day free trial of
any and all courses on the site.
Just go to Lynda.com/Veritasium or click the
link in the description.
You know one of the courses I’m really interested
in is Adobe After Effects.
That’s a really good animating software.
Right now I still do all of my animations
including the ones in this video in Final
Cut Pro which is really tedious and time consuming.
Now if you’re interested in learning how
to program maybe you should try out their
Java courses.
Those are really good.
Or if like me you’ve always wanted to do
more with Photoshop, you should try out one
of their Photoshop or photography courses.
So if you want to learn something new today,
you should go to Lynda.com/Veritasium for
10 days free trial.
There’s really nothing to lose me.
I really want to thank Lynda.com for supporting
me, and I want to thank you for watching.